joe biden just went to visit michigan so
occasionally he tries to get out of the
house it's good for him to get fresh air
it's good for him to get a little
exercise you know remember what day it
is so so joe biden goes to michigan and
as he's driving up in the presidential
motorcade
there are people chanting
f joe biden f joe biden also known as
let's go brandon there are signs that
say f joe biden
and joe biden gets to his campaign stop
he's standing in front of a caterpillar
piece of you know big big heavy
equipment and he's good american
manufacturing good american farm jobs
he's an all-american guy and joe biden
has the audacity
to
claim that he is the most popular
president american history won more
votes than anyone else
i took this agenda to the country
they said it was time to build an
economy that looks out from scranton
pennsylvania where i grew up as a kid
instead of looking down from wall street
an economy looks out from howell
michigan and towns like it all over
america that brings people from every
race background religion into the game
that's what and notwithstanding some of
the signs i saw come that's why 81
million americans voted for me
the largest number of votes in american
history
a clear majority
were supported
when they supported me
so joe biden
he he's clearly irritated by the let's
go brandon stuff and by the signs
because he references the signs
right he says notwithstanding some of
those signs that i saw you know all the
ones people saying how much they hate my
guts uh i got the most votes of anyone
in american history i'm so popular
81 million and then what do you hear in
the crowd did you hear that all that
excitement you just hear this you're
like yeah
uh-huh 80 uh they're like six people out
in the crowd
you actually when joe biden first got
there he walks in you know he wants to
make his rock star entrance by the way i
know it's easy to forget this guy is
supposed to be the president of the
united states right you want to walk out
you want to walk out too proud to be an
american with 50 000 people there just
like at the trump rallies whoo yeah joe
biden woo the president
what happens he walks out here's his
response
hello michigan
it's good to be back
hello michigan
that is i think indicative
of something that we talk about a lot on
this show which is the the difference
between
the appearance of how things are and how
things really are
the
huge gap the chasm between what our
ruling class
tells us the world is like and the the
situation on the ground is and what the
real situation on the ground is so what
the ruling class says is
joe biden
got the most votes ever he got 70
gazillion votes
and more than no i think 700 000
gazillion votes and it was he's the most
popular president ever in american
history and yeah never mind that no one
showed up to his rallies and never mind
that in order for for him to win the
white house we had to change all of the
election rules and you know spend days
and weeks counting it and uh never mind
that people keep booing him everywhere
there's a crowd in the entire country at
sports games at concerts and everything
no he got a gazillion billion zillion
votes and he's super duper popular and
then there's the reality which is
anywhere this guy goes people boo him
and they heckle him and all of the
public opinion polls are saying that
he's deeply deeply unpopular even the
ones that are supposed to skew to his
side all say
no one likes him
nobody really believes
that joe biden is the most popular
president ever no one believes it even
the people who are claiming it to you do
not really believe it they're we're all
just lying to one another and to
ourselves if if we are reciting the
left-wing dominant narrative okay it's
it's sad
but everyone seems to be comfortable
with with the fact that we're living in
lies i'm so glad you enjoyed that clip
that makes me feel really good if you
want to catch the whole show you can do
it here ring the bell subscribe on
youtube you get the whole show here or
if you don't want to be censored quite
as much as we are sometimes by our
friends over here then you can go to
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your podcasts for
free and subscribe to the michael
knowles show go do it maybe leave a five
star review that'd be nice i'd
appreciate it we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you